three pill wrestle NBA Finals Most
Valuable Player award here's ABC's Lisa
Salters
thank you
joined by Denver Nuggets chairman Stan
Conkey and vice chairman Josh grunke
here to present the Larry O'Brien trophy
to the Denver Nuggets NBA Commissioner
Adam Silver
Thank you Lisa and to the Miami Heat
congratulations our Eastern Conference
champion
what an incredible game we saw tonight
Stan and Josh cronke Calvin booth
Michael Malone what a fantastic job
you've done
47 years for the Denver Nuggets
congratulations
you were the 2023
NBA champions
and now the Larry O'Brien trophy
[Applause]
thank you
miss Mr cronky
like the commissioner said the drought
the drought is over what does this
trophy mean to this city unbelievable
the fans were the fans in this town are
unbelievable as you can see Lisa
unbelievable and so it means a lot to us
to be able to get this done and the fans
we couldn't have done it without them so
fantastic
congratulations to coach the players the
whole organization but you got to love
that City
[Applause]
you've recently said that Nicola jokic
is the most amazing thing you've ever
seen in basketball why do you say that
well because I watched yoke early come
in and work out and I think he's been
described as a chubby teenager but no
one really
uh they underestimated his resolve and
his work ethic is unbelievable player
and so we're just happy to be
participating I mean I watch a lot of
basketball I played a lot of basketball
but yolks are unbelievable amazing
player we've got when we've got a bunch
of them thank you sir congratulations
coach come on over here
you've been a coach Malone you've been
around basketball your entire life
the work
all of the work all of the sacrifices
how does that trophy make it all worth
it
first off a huge shout out to nuggets
Nation we love you guys we love you guys
best fans in the world
all the hard work all the sacrifice all
the dedication all culminated with us
winning a championship but I got news
for everybody out there we're not
satisfied with one we want more
[Music]
oh yeah
let's give out Nicole as well because I
know he's not going to talk about
himself but his historic performance in
these playoffs just you talk about him
what does it say about your Superstar
well Nicola jokic is a great person he's
a great husband father and son and
brother and on the basketball court he's
proven time and time again that he's the
best player in the NBA he's our MVP we
love him and we thankful like wearing a
nugget uniform thank you congratulations
[Applause]